- So …
Das Hemd ist toll.
- Ja, das gefällt mir.
- Die Jacke auch?
- Super.
- Nein, die ist besser.
Wie süß!
Wie findest du die Farbe?
Für mich!
Wie findest du das Hemd?
- Wie viel kostet das?
- Ehm … 25 Euro.
Ist das okay?
- Ja, das ist okay.
- Super!
Das steht dir gut!
- Ja, das passt auch.
Wie findest du den Pullover?
- Schön.
Probier mal das andere Hemd an.
Welche Größe ist das?
- Ich weiß nicht.
- L.
Probier mal M an. Das ist zu groß.
Ja, die Jacke steht dir sehr gut.
Das finde ich schön.
So! Bitte schön.
- Vielen Dank.
- Eigentlich wollte ich gar nichts kaufen.
- Aber die Jacke …
die Jacke steht dir sehr gut.
- Das hat Spaß gemacht.
Gib mal deine Hand!
Nein …
Falls du mal wieder einkaufen willst.
- Wo ist meine Tasche?
- Da vorne!